when you get drunk it numbs the part of
you that would normally laugh at
yourself for doing something sexy when
your drunken life is this your scarf
this is a very nice scarf like I'm Kate
Beckinsale like I
[Music]
we need some sort of patch yeah like a
wine pad like a one cause of Pinot Noir
that's very good
yeah you just put it on you know like
your lips get purple some sort of patch
that gives you the this sort of the lack
of inhibition that booze gives you but
it isn't actually alcohol whatever that
is I think it's some oxy yes he's cool
trying to get Mickey at a union square
it has a dog on the train going I need
to take it home for Buffalo you know
you're on heroin I know you're
on the thing is we may now know which
one to figure out problems is to suggest
alongside the machine why not a
nice audio book then you've got company
yeah during the machine or have
guys say let's go in and make a full
robot for Nicky that's weird
science can't wait till those exist
million followers on Instagram
first of all I have a small apartment
I'm gonna get roll out my machine
what does my man look sure my mate is
gonna like dust around - you know I'll
hold on real quick this way oh I was
just gassing up this thing real quick
but that's where the audio book comes in
handy
what do you mean I may be a Charles
Dickens best of times I could just like
watch porn and put on the with you
I mean like I will a hundred percent by
a machine you have a bunch of
locks on it where you go you guys want
to see the room that's a big machine I
do I have come up with a way to have to
get without a machine on
your own okay there's one that there's
toys that like move on their own right
like they have like a bend in them and
it goes like right Ariary
it swirls it looks like it's a small
world after all at Disneyland like the
way they move like do a come-hither
motion okay yeah so a lot of times I'll
but I don't even want to hold it there
because I'm just like then I have to be
in this like weird crunch position so
I've plugged my heel with it and then
laid back half and then it's working and
you're not doing anything and you're
just getting good you're gonna get this
like a lifetime but for sex toys that
looks like you're gonna get a cramp of
some form and I put a dimmer switch on
my Hitachi which I'm sitting on I just
put that on my butt and sit on that and
I have a dimmer switch with that so I'm
doing minimal well there is a Japanese
scientist that is so upset you don't
know about its products you need to put
your heel on the do not worry if I
was a woman and I a machine it
would just kill me the thing genuine is
so very that you do it too wildly and it
would make a citizen's arrest
yeah the robot would just take you into
this dream did you just lift you up by
your face they have the UK they're
developing sex robots in the UK one in
five
British people said they would have sex
with the robots yeah with you because
you're afraid of it Wallace and Gromit
at least you liked it too much I would
say basically this like a cartoon so
basically there's this or robot I would
worry that the robot would just take you
out in the street exam on this
interesting thing yeah it's an actual
sex robots they've developed it with the
Scottish accent really yeah
every tool though is a robot in some way
whose robot the remote control No so
you're doing the same line of thinking
that men do it bars or they're just
trying to hook up and you go what is a
robot what is sex what is yeah I'm gonna
a machine so what it's just I'm
worried your turn damn did you did you
struggle with having sex sober after you
got sober no you definitely don't come
right away when that happens okay it
definitely happens you quit drinking
like sex I've done yep yeah oh my god
but I mean getting to the place where
you can be comfortable enough to have
sex I feel like guys are gonna fish
yeah what's worse to try to have sex is
to drink a bunch of caffeine yeah so
much creepier when my drunk friends were
get sober and drink redbull to stay up
we're like wait around 2:30 no I can't
yeah that's creepy yeah you know
what I mean like you're waiting for just
like a wounded deer I've turned got you
drunk and I'm like yeah we're not gonna
you know that's yeah I'm sure now you
see it so yeah yeah but you're like stop
oh no you don't oh sweet oh sweet thing
no you know I know it's hard to put up
with and sexy now I need you go you go I
used to feel oh I know exactly what
you're feeling right now but it's not I
would make you so many promises right
now if I was hammered oh well I just
talked about the first time that I was
tested as a sober person like at my
favorite thing to do drunk I was talking
about Andrea like some of my best like
my best memories are like when I drank
and had fun and going to Lollapalooza
and getting wasted was my favorite
yearly thing to do and the first time I
went sober was with you she was still
drinking and you were still Trisha
yeah and it was that was like such a
test from in then I never went back
again like you can't do music festivals
do you do without drunk Bay there's
certain things that you can't do
anything that's a good point our music
festival was a tough one to do that they
felt long I'm saying Coachella for the
first time two years ago and that blew
my mind and I wasn't drinking there
really you just there stone so just but
what I'd never been to an American music
festival war just compared to like
Glastonbury in England is the same but
completely different like this show it
was incredible yeah everyone was just as
soon as the band started everyone turned
around and we're kind of filming it with
themself in it so yeah performers yeah
performers were performing tonight yeah
American fans give it up for the band
comedy audiences here are amazing but
like to compare to the UK yeah but I'm
doing fringe this year and I'm like
yeah I'm at the dairy underbelly all of
these stuff yeah yeah just fine I'm
worried that you said that because
you're like they're not good well my
thing is I don't think because Americans
don't have much holidays you have two
weeks holiday so I think when you go out
it has to matter whereas in the UK we
have five weeks off so yeah your
vacation time I think I think you put so
much energy into an evening out
because you have to work so hard in this
country that you you are gonna make sure
it's good so you get I just think
there's at least one personalist thing
that when you say there you go god damn
right we work hard hammering barns but a
music festival just bloom and there was
in Coachella late with certain areas
where you were allowed to take booze but
others you weren't yeah we basically are
still children like you know we're a
music festival that's what like if you
go to like Glastonbury yeah like I
remember driving like I was backstage I
was doing a gig there I'm kind of
driving a car through and there's like
little time with thousands I'm like
driving through time and there's this
guy this guy's shit-faced probably about
like 50 at the time and I turned to my
girlfriend that's my uncle like in the
middle of all these people this this old
guy that was just bollixed and that's
what the UK gigs alike just let you know
music gigs people just wasted on there's
always one bloke that will wake up and
glass to me after the first workout in
eggs in some factory he's been stolen by
some Christians in some weird car just
shipped off mate it's proper wild so it
was amazing to see everyone's dressed so
cute
have you been to Coachella before I feel
like that Bonnaroo twice got it yeah
Bonnaroo blast amis worth going to
though if you want to go to if you want
to sort of see in a side of England that
you probably haven't seen in the films
that come out over here yeah there and
you'll see a wild side
just getting you guys just get
hammered yeah it's great but leaking is
more I feel like in the UK drinking is a
lot more I saw the Pudge yeah we
can drink it too only you get off
earlier are we it's just very unhappy
people we just guess do you miss
drinking ever
sometimes well I had a moment about two
weeks ago where I could feel the back of
my jaw starting to water and I
was like I just want a shot at whiskey
and a beer
really and then that immediately
like that's why I shouldn't have it yeah
so we stopped just because you you just
you will just go what's selling walk by
like a really Irish you know dive bar
and he said but you think what you won't
just have one you'll just have
okay ain't coming back for one yeah I
think I'm just gonna stay sweetie cuz my
friend al is is an alcoholic and he
hasn't like and he is exactly always
fascinates me yeah that you just can't
have that I always was blown away I I'm
more upset with people that can have a
drink and walk away I think yeah I think
you're the weirdos right yeah
okay I stay there to the very end
commitment seeing something through did
you ever I used to say to my friends I'd
be like let's get blackout oh my god I
had one Apple I would do this set me so
much because one time he put half a beer
down and he goes I'm gonna walk out of
here I don't want that half a beer and I
go I'm gonna drink that beer and he goes
that's why I put it right there because
that's who you are
yeah back it ain't it ain't I
handshake and how you doing well
you were going to Scotland for a month
already know it's gonna be tough I know
that every single person I know that
knows I'm going over there is they're
like alright yeah cool I mean I've
already asked my publicist I was like I
need weed I just do whatever yeah I
smoke weed I'll give you a sexual if you
want yes I can have my penis crushed is
a you see the sex robot drinking this
this what lubricates my robotic vagina
is Guinness yeah with weed would what do
you I struggle with that and I talk
about a lot on the show is that I you
know I love weed and it doesn't ruin my
life the way alcohol did and I can still
function highly function sure literally
on weed do you feel the same do you ever
feel guilty about it do you ever feel
like hey I'm gonna stop doing this
so we're cuz that rubbing your hands
together and getting hammered thing I'm
like I'm doing this radio show I'm going
home and getting crap I'm
smoking a joy I'm gonna watch that
documentary about Elizabeth and that
yeah I it I get high the way I you know
drink yes very very high very high I
love it and I love it too i have the
same and racine my when I get done with
shows I'm like I get to em and see we
used to talk about this and you're like
you know what
I uh I do it as like a tree you do the
whole like like I do it I do it only
after shows I do it when I get home I
eat my salad Dan doesn't smoke weed
before his sets I gotta be more like Dan
thank you for admitting that you do now
oh my god what's what it is is it's like
is to the point where like you know
getting high I think I about getting
high the same way he's talked about
quitting drinking right like I don't
drink whiskey I only have yes yes ateva
yeah that's what it is only indica yeah
I know like it's you give me
dirt weed yep
you can be honest you with all
smoke but when you had when you did the
gravity bong hit and you ended up pure
gravity bong it do you know what you're
talking about be honest with you I
because we does not is we not big in the
UK as much as it is here not as this
sort of a teenage thing no you sort of
just you just drink from like 14 and the
UK and that's where as you guys start
off we been with yeah we're already in
pups I think yeah so you guys are
because you can go into a pub and just
have a have a pint and there's always
one place where sometimes you go and let
you in and everyone kind of goes in in
here in America they really are like no
oh yeah never drink I'll continue Kay
yeah you sort of still do here I smoked
pot with my mum in Portland last year
for a TV show that we did I was it was
great fun yeah my mum had never done it
before
really
yeah no I was gonna say yeah my mom used
to get high in the 60s and 70s oh really
and then it got legal in Colorado they
smoke weed with you and they smoked weed
and it's not fun watching your mom not
be able to handle or what it was
fun is watching your mom being like what
was this girl's this girl that ran this
this shop we kind of went back to our
place and we kind of did various
versions of it she had this lovely
little chihuahua and by the end of the
session you could tell them my mum was
eyeing up that dog to eat like January
we were kind of going I said would you
have in that dog show you would have
definitely to put it on a George Foreman
grill eating it in a bun yeah well the
dog seemed to be like these guys are new
yeah that's watching your mom seeing
your parents get hot like my parents get
when I see them hi I love my mom hi
delight and she likes filming things
that's her new thing when she gets high
she will just start filming us and
cabinetry and like around the house
she's a document the house because I
think they're gonna sell it soon so she
and I go dad what is she doing yo such
her mom's new thing because my mom
always has a new thing when she gets
up that she like she like for
many years she was calling us all or she
would fire us if we got mad she'd be
like you're fired and that was we be
like mom fired me three times last night
my mom says hello to me all the time
what you get here hello my mom would get
whine teeth and they get like purple you
know she would just cry about things
that don't exist anymore like she be
like dinosaur she's like the Osco drug
closed I used to buy your birthday card
like crying like are we really crying
because a drug store closed yeah
my mom didn't reckon a 40 minute long
improvised song when she was drunk two
Christmases ago taking my nan shopping
there was this great moment where about
ten minutes in my dad turned to my
brother went go get the camera to record
half-hour we're she like grabbing her
ear like getting into it lots of my
cousins playing band so there we saw her
just playing along a mum just grabbed it
and it was down the aisle it was in
another way so we have we have all the
vouchers we have like do you have like
collecting vouchers for school yeah so
that's a big thing in the UK or like
nectar cards and all that kind of so she
did like a sort of a freestyle rap about
no hammered moms I mean we really she
yeah she fires us and then for a while
was biatches she called everyone be just
just learned that word loved it and now
she's filming people cool beans you know
what they should do is we should do a
competition where you know where you're
driving
kind of like carpool karaoke you have to
drive to a city and they get your mom
hammered and you had she gets in the car
and you have to drive her there oh my
god could you make it
anymore hammer that is such a good show
I would I've done that I mean I traveled
all across America with my mom really
and yet for TV show and then Thailand in
India well I was in a traffic jam with
my mum whilst sober and I'm famous in
the UK so this guy kind of got out we
were in traffic knocked on the window
and twitch gives me can I have a photo
it was fairly strange and my mum way
help he's kidnapping me Oh Oh your mom's
hilarious oh yeah after so why'd you do
that and she said because I'm 60 and I
don't give a I love you so that was
her sober so drunk I took around the
well that makes sense why and now you
have like I also use my parents a lot in
my show and come when I had a show on
Comedy Central and also like my mom
calls in to this show oh really
I just realize like when she passes away
at some point like I'm gonna have all
this great footage and people are like
why don't you take a blow job class with
your mom and I'm like cuz it's funny and
I'm gonna look back on it and they're
like when your mom's funeral is god
forbid it's in many many years it's
gonna be like we won't have those
traditional kind of like oh yeah I
remember her like I'll remember her in a
cacao ceremony in Thailand yes you have
all these weird kind of strange moment
yeah just remember playing solitaire in
a room in the dark that's the reason why
I saw I did it beautiful beautiful I'll
never forget that but when she's eating
a hot dog with no bun with too much
ketchup with our hands that's pretty
cool I assumed she might you know you
know what neck screw you that's a super
super say screw you Ashley Hesseltine
and Rayna Greenberg run the show
yesterday's show with Andrew there was a
picture that we posted I posted on my
story and I cut Andrew out because
three girl I just wanted to celebrate
women yeah and not you and then I posted
another picture where it was just you
and it didn't feel at first I thought it
was like like a like a dig but then I
was like oh no it's kind of nice like
you showed me again like you cut me out
but then put me in but at first I took
it as a dig and I want to be a dick I'm
gonna white her out and so then I have
made you a penis and then I posted it
for a second and then I go wait that's
just mean-spirited yeah you just threw
me as a big and it looks like that looks
like it doesn't look like a penis you
didn't even do it the right color it's
just a white blob yeah it looks like I'm
but I felt like that was probably a
little rude and so I deleted it right
away well I'm glad you showed it to me
right now oh my god I know what I want
to do can I get a pen and paper I just
want a challenge Andrew to draw
something you know that guy from Brazil
I was telling you about so their night
he was talking about how like oh he's
gonna move to New York because the
flight to Brazil is so much shorter than
it is from LA and I was like well I
guess that checks out and he's like yeah
like they're an hour ahead right now and
I was like what do you mean they're an
hour ahead an hour
Brazil from where New York okay and I
was like that does not match up with
where I think Brazil is and then I
realized my perception of where South
America is is so wrong can I ask you I
just want to see if I miss because I
mean this was embarrassing in front of
someone from South America to see where
I thought South America was in
comparison to North America was I'm
gonna draw you draw from Florida I think
I might have a better sense because from
st. Louis yeah
like I don't know Missouri Kansas I
couldn't tell you those oh well that
would be a fun one to make you draw then
so what do you want me to draw here um
North America and South America and they
can be blobs I'm not gonna like check if
you know and don't even put Canada who
cares yeah no one does this is the
second time we've done this like all of
that someone wrote to me being like I
heard you uh throw some
oh wait a second
I mean maybe we're not gonna get at
least not to scale that's not that's not
to nothing what do you you don't need to
draw like islands and Stream Delta's he
put in the Bahamas no okay okay what is
that
Mexico okay I think that's I don't is
that Florida right there that and then I
would say somewhere I know there's Chile
is over here mm-hmm
and then Brazil is around here it
doesn't matter I just want the shapes of
South America and North America well
just start over this looks like a
crude drawing of a suspect first of all
he thinks that's Florida no no that's
California that's that's Florida yeah
and then this was Mexico
so Mexico starts it and he said before
he drew this he said I might know this a
little bit better because I'm from
Florida he connected Florida and Mexico
you guys do you know god that's a you
want to build that wall well actually
that wall the border doesn't even exist
that you want to build up hold on we
have to just see I'm sorry the podcast
is gonna wait for a second cuz I need to
make you draw this okay so draw just the
crude shapes blobs of South America and
just I wanna see their location to each
other okay that's America and then I
would say it's somewhere around here and
then
that and then okay and then there's like
chili I don't mean that's not even close
for Chile or Brazil our chilies on this
side by the way Chili's on the right
it's chili on the right or left Chili's
on this side it's cold
okay okay this is way worse than I
thought it was gonna be and I'm so
excited about it because I thought well
that goes in between and they're Central
America night Anderson I'm gonna blow
your pull up pull up of world map I'm
gonna blow your mind right now
first of all I thought this as well this
was what my drawing looked like okay
first of all we live in a mirror this is
what my drawing looks like the other
night that's where I was like okay right
okay that's up now mine farther away
similar right okay okay look at a map of
where South America is compared to to
the United do a globe to north just pull
up Google Maps and then zoom out oh he's
loading transit maps for San Antonio for
some reason you never know keep zooming
keep going Oh God
isn't it worse than you thought dude
okay we're in second all right no one
knows it's to the right
no one okay so this is where it is okay
we've both thought I never knew that I
thought if you go down from LA you would
hit South America immediately I didn't
know it Vince by the way you don't hit
anything if you go south yeah from New
York
you hit nothing nothing North America is
completely to the left so why is it not
South East America I don't know I feel
like we need to get this message out
there because clearly people don't know
I really thought it was right under us
is there north was america and north and
south called at the same time or was one
found because they didn't both at the
same time i don't know well i was there
an organ is named after Amerigo Vespucci
okay who was a dis for Gucci yeah yeah
in front of his house if I guess we
can't get into all this we know all of
this we know all like we could discuss
this for hours about
it is always kind of knowing when to
dump people are like or aam Dom no no
I'm I'm really dumb about judging we go
oh and Google exists back in the day
you'd be like well you got to go to the
library or whatever or like you got to
phone a friend yeah but now it's like
shut up stop sounding stupid and google
it but then again it's like I have no
idea what America came first and maybe
we shouldn't call it South America
because it is south of America but maybe
we're north of South America so we
should be north South America do you and
I mean like it should start with South
America and that we like you know in
south well yeah I'm just saying like why
are we just calling in South America are
we calling it like trying to be its own
thing I get what you're saying like
yours Australia there's Africa no I know
so it should be North America why do we
even look at the why do we look at world
map from the Advanta vantage point that
we all do where it's like this the in
Asia is over here ever like why couldn't
it be upside down because who's to say
how to look at the world what's right
side up and what's not we're really
smart and we can talk about this all day
but we got to get to there is something
that is a thing there's um I don't think
the earth is flat give it that yeah no
no I you don't know why you don't the
earth isn't flat no something about if
you fly a plane
you won't you gotta go around oh that's
funny you gotta you gotta go like down
you got to make a turn at one point yeah
you probably are you just go into space
yeah all right learn something yeah if
you're on uh welcome mapping that was
fun let's start the podcast ready are
you ready I'm ready
all right hey guys welcome to you up the
podcast
you